Prince Charles talking to people in Fish
Lake six weeks
after hundreds of homes were flooded
when the river Don overflowed he met
some of the emergency workers who helped
people out of their flooded houses and
those who've been working on the ongoing
cleanup among them local farmers who
pressed their claim that a lack of River
maintenance is to blame they told me
they hope a word in the Royal ear will
help there's no point talking to the
officials on the ground they were just
in the local departments it's got to
come from higher up to get them to act
Royals rarely get to see Britain as it
really is so the council swept Fish Lake
to within an inch of its life
just before he arrived and on the newly
cleaned streets one well-wisher took the
opportunity to ask after the Duke of
Edinburgh who was taken to hospital on
Friday with an undisclosed condition
Prince Charles spent more than an hour
and a half in Fish Lake and villagers
said his time was appreciated I think
it's really helped lift their spirits
it's been a really difficult time over
in Fish Lake so yes thanks very much
most people are out the houses still and
I need some money spending on the flood
defences and things so it doesn't happen
again next year so it's good to raise
the profile of it on Prince Charles's
visit undoubtedly raised spirits in a
village where for many Christmas 2019
will be less than perfect
Toronto Sky News Fish Lake